FDMA and TDMA are the two answers to the
oldest question in radio: how do many
conversations share one band without
talking over each other?
The first answer is frequency-division
multiple access.
Slice the band into non-overlapping
channels, and give each call its own
frequency for the whole duration.
Call A on one channel, call B on the next,
small guard bands between them so
neighbors don't interfere.
Capacity scales the obvious way: more
conversations means more channels.
Its virtue is simplicity — no timing to
coordinate, tolerant of distance and delay
— which is why it carried early
land-mobile radio.
Its cost is that a quiet talker still ties
up a whole frequency.
So the industry narrowed the slices
instead: twenty-five kilohertz FM became
the twelve-and-a-half of P25 Phase 1, and
the six-and-a-quarter of NXDN.
The second answer divides time instead.
Time-division multiple access splits one
frequency into rapid, repeating timeslots,
and calls take turns.
Call one bursts in slot one, call two in
slot two, back to call one — many times
per second, fast enough that each
conversation sounds perfectly continuous.
One channel now does the work of two.
The price is discipline.
Every radio must burst exactly inside its
slot, so bursts are padded with a little
guard time, and receivers lock onto a
frame-synchronization pattern to learn
where the slot boundaries fall.
In exchange, DMR and P25 Phase 2 double
the calls per frequency with two slots,
and TETRA packs four calls onto one
carrier.
A subscriber radio even saves battery by
switching its transmitter off between
bursts.
Real systems combine both: FDMA
channelizes the band, TDMA time-shares
each channel.
And for trunking, the difference shows up
in the grant itself — on FDMA a grant
names a frequency; on TDMA it must name a
frequency and a slot.
For an SDR, the split is concrete.
On FDMA, a granted channel is simply a
carrier: GopherTrunk down-converts that
frequency from the wideband capture and
demodulates it.
On TDMA, the same carrier holds two or
four unrelated calls, so GopherTrunk must
also recover burst timing, sync to the
frame, and pull out just the granted slot
— which is exactly what its DMR, P25 Phase
2, and TETRA decode paths do.
So: FDMA gives each call its own
frequency; TDMA lets calls share one
frequency in timeslots, doubling or
quadrupling capacity at the cost of tight
timing — and on TDMA, every grant names a
slot as well as a channel.
Full write-ups linked below.